hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time uh
september 21st will be in san antonio
september 22nd we're going to be in
houston september 23rd to the 25th we're
going to be in austin for the moon tower
comedy festival ever heard of it
then uh dallas fort worth on september
26th and we're bringing it back up north
baby uh september 30th we're going to be
in long island
and then
what are we doing we're going home for
cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're gonna be at
helium comedy club in philadelphia get
those tickets they're gonna move fast
i'm telling you yeah do it yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r.u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grow up to be classy
yeah or is it just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here aunt toddy's basement yeah the
summer has come to an end we got a
truckload of pumpkins in the backyard
really wants us to start moving some
pumpkins well your hot streak's done
i had a couple of good ones the last
couple weeks he got me working
he got me two weeks in a row with the
toddy bit my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused he is the
ceo of ru garbage he is an international
businessman he is not trifled with in
the boardroom before he has had his
coffee i can promise you that give it up
for kevin james ryan hey gang happy to
be here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are screw the
roof through the [ __ ] roof it's
cooking and then i would be remissed an
[ __ ] a jerk off if i didn't mention
the greatest website of all time
out to the am www.patreon.com out to mr
yam and family and company uh you can
sign up for patreon you get bonus
episodes of ayg hard feelings live
streams the whole [ __ ] night there's
videos we did the cribs video of my
childhood house your childhood house the
[ __ ] wildwood everything's on there
check it out go yes sir and how about a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he just had a weekend
with the homies skating around tearing
up new york city grinding rails whatever
the [ __ ] they do give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby tony hawk mcmullen what's
up dudes
oh man i got the twins at the crib
they're here for a week i'm about to get
evicted oh i could imagine christ
two more bigger dirt balls than you
hanging out in that same apartment they
brought foldable cots
that place probably smells like seventh
grade
[Laughter]
but gang we could not be more excited
and i mean not be more excited to have
our incredibly and i mean incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time he has a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian writer
actor and podcaster he was one of the
writers for the white house
correspondents dinner he was a writer on
not safe with nikki glazer 20 episodes
of that 21 episodes of superior donuts
on cbs nine episodes of the break with
michelle wolf ten episodes of
alternatino on comedy central he wrote
on the roast of rob lowe he's been on
best week ever he's been on adam ruins
everything crashing this week at the
comedy cellar wtf with mark maron late
night with jimmy fallon the nightly show
with larry wilmore at midnight conan got
his own comedy central presents he's got
a brand new sketch show coming up that
he worked on called immoral compass
presented by bill burr gonna be on roku
check it out he has an amazing album out
called no real winners and of course is
the host of wrestle rose podcast but the
big question on his mind today is he
garbage
visually he looks like he needs a hot
shower
divorce attorney yeah yeah yeah ladies
and gentlemen give it up for the one the
only mr dan saint germain thank you guys
that was such a that's the that's how we
do it i repeat that in the mirror when i
think about putting
it's just a matter of time before the
bookings come back you do the hank
kingsley voice in the mirror
[Laughter]
buddy thank you so much for coming in
thanks for having me you guys have a
great podcast hot podcast thanks for
having me i appreciate it
thanks for having me you know just just
giving me another shot you know
what are we doing here
[Laughter]
hey i got these cds if you guys want to
buy these cds
we were doing we were doing our due
diligence our research i couldn't find
anything about your personal life like
where you're from where's your home
planet what's the deal i guess that was
what
i grew up in rutherford new jersey and
then
i was seventh grade
then we went to westchester so it was
like a step up nice and then i went to
school in evansville indiana no wait
hold on step up that's a [ __ ] that's
a gigantic yeah that's that's an
escalator to the moon yeah we we moved
because my mom lost the pta election oh
my god
local
ran her out of town on a railway
she's like [ __ ] this place
[Laughter]
she's getting trump down to mar largo
she really is
yeah she's like a thinner skin trump
holy [ __ ] so
so
yeah that went to scotland you know new
york in l.a back and forth yeah okay
then new york now now what
when you say
rutherford new jersey talking about east
rutherford rutherford not east
rutherford east rutherford i wrestled
for east rutherford and then rutherford
that's like the what rutherford's like a
little bit more hoity-toity that's like
the william carlos williams wait this is
where uh what's it called is right giant
stadium is eve rutherford or metlife no
where's uh what am i thinking of rutgers
where's
we were just rutgers like four days ago
all right fair enough um but they have
yeah like rutherford the most like
i guess trash thing they have is they
have like this cowboy depot
uh store that's clearly a mob run okay
it's like yeah what do you want
want vests
we got spurs we got saturn
we got that thing you put in the [ __ ]
mouth when you pull them when they ain't
doing what you wanna do like i've never
seen anyone shop there and it's a guy in
like a wife beater who like it looks
like the opposite of a western
you know
jersey has do they do have those weird
pockets of hillbilly of like hicks like
down in south jersey has like the cow
town i just know
is the only place where
someone will appropriate
uh black culture while using the n-word
with a hard er yeah
south jersey's it's a it's a mix of a
lot of bad things yeah it's a lot it's
it's it's everybody wants to be philly
at south jersey everybody has to be
feeling that's where i went to rehab was
it sea brookhouse what up south jersey
saint germain's really giving it up
quick isn't it three minutes in repping
and prepping his halfway house
we offer you a soda you start confessing
to the murders
geez just put on a poker face for a
couple of minutes call an attorney so uh
we're done here
i don't think o.j did it
just get that out of the way is the
family
is the family from
rutherford is that with your cousins
and and rather when hurst and rutherford
yeah and did you have with arlington did
you have a big extended family down
there
no it's it was it was i mean you know
cousins
both sides like one was very blue collar
my dad's a writer so he's wasn't it was
like he's like a he's like a mix of like
like hoity-toity and trash it's kind of
it's like blade what kind of writing a
vampire half you i got you uh he's a
playwright and he also he wrote tv you
wrote on the cosby show which used to be
a cool credit
that he he wrote um he's written a
couple movies and [ __ ] like holy [ __ ]
nice all right but uh you know mike his
side of the family it's all like my
grandpa who like worked for nabisco and
then my uncle's a mechanic my aunt's a
nurse and then my mom's side of the
family is like there's well not
everybody like i'm really close with my
cousin sam uh and then there's some
people who are like you know it's like
really smart people who also went to
jail
you know
it's like that kind of combo uh so you
know a lot of people who you know died
falling off ladders you know
kind of that kind of crew
real date wine real last start of the
day yeah yeah all right we'll start with
playwright
that's pretty clear that's a good stock
though yeah
where did he go to school cultured at
least uh seton hall not a bad school at
school now did he come from a little bit
of cash or was it no not real i mean not
i mean like you know my grandpa worked
for nabisco
uh and then he worked at a nuclear power
plant i think so it wasn't like it
wasn't like it wasn't like mailman money
but it wasn't ceo but yeah he's like a
weird you know my grandpa was like a
smart guy but like uh you know he voted
for obama but then my dad my dad wrote
the nelson mandela movie like one of the
iterations that my grandpa gave him for
a present they thought it would be joke
a spear
you know cause like and i'm like that's
like
you know like so my grandpa still has
like he's dead now but he still had like
that racist like jersey sure [ __ ] my
grandpa oh yeah my grandpa would my dad
was just like what the
nelson mandel you know like like are you
you know so it was like that kind of
like it was like the combo your dad
wrote a nelson mandela movie and as it
was he wrote yeah as a because he's like
oh africa here's a spear like you know
there's like north jersey [ __ ] that
radiation got to his head i gotta tell
you that's a weird switch nabisco to
nuclear power plant one day you're
making fun stripes and the next day
you're handling [ __ ] he was you know
like yeah he was an interesting guy you
know he's war hero uh my other grandpa
like got discharged because he shot
himself in the hand but but because he
was drunk but your mains are a rough
bunch of great enough early on this
kid's coming in hot and i like it the
other grandpa was like uh
he free concentration camps and [ __ ] so
the racist one freed concentration camps
you're like chunk and goonies when he's
confessing everything to the fratellis
put his hands in the blood
all right i'll just slow down what was
the westchester life like so you leave
there we went to pound ridge which is
like the opposite of white trash it's
like very hamilty it's actually like new
cane in the town right next to us you
remember that movie the ice storm of
course yeah so that's exactly where it
was you know playing nacho you know like
um
like key parties and all that kind of
[ __ ] and uh you know country clubs and
went to public school there but where's
the coin coming from to make this move
uh my dad was my dad had no money then
he had money uh-huh and then he had no
money again very irish really wow that
just that was my dad your parents are
still together
no divorce stay divorced does he have
parents still together face
i don't know if you're picking up on
what i am are we in the same podcast
right now are your parents still
together
lucky as a shirt
like a bare minimum of a compliment oh
you got real parents stole together's
face
yeah
well this guy
did you guys all moved to westchester
together was what i was getting at yeah
we did yeah brothers and sisters sister
yeah she's younger older younger she's
um uh
runs like an english language company
now or for online she's great we're
really close so she was lives in the
city how far away how how much younger
is she than you four years okay so not
bad so you guys the parents are still
together you guys moved to westchester
your dad just sold something or he was
working on one yeah yeah he had i mean
he had a really good run for a little
bit you know he was selling a lot of
movies and then
you know and then it just kind of
stopped you know when she hit 50 like
it's just i get everything
yeah yeah she could just stop
and what was the scene in westchester
like country clubs
well i didn't know not not for us um but
like we had a really nice you know we
had a nice house for sure
um and uh but it was it was a public
high school but it was kind of
interesting because it would be like um
because there's a lot of rich kids who
went to public high school but then they
also like would bust in group home kids
like um so it was almost like that you
know like in the time machine they talk
about like every once in a while like
like like so like like some preppy white
kid would like get big vs bridges and
then somebody from the group would just
just [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of it of
course like it was this weird like kind
of like uh like stability was checks and
balances checks and balance yeah what's
the time machine it was that that that
book the the time hd you thought we
would get a reference
they bring it up in the in the movie
ransom so i thought you guys would know
gary sinise used it a lot so i figured
you guys would know that not a bad movie
i'm going to tell you that right now
that's a real sleeper dude there's a
whole thing where he talks about the
time machine he's like that kid pieces
that blew my mind you never know
people that use the one book they've
read yeah you ever read the book of moby
dick
i do that all the time he does it with
books he's never read yeah i recommend
books to people i've never read it's a
really good read you should try it out
here
um you went to college
yeah where'd you go university of
evansville in indiana what what major
what what how'd you get out there i got
i don't know why my mascot is the
six-pack
it's actually a pimp it's the purple ace
the purple hd that's the yeah that's the
way is that real yeah
they were a really good division three
basketball team and then they changed d1
and got their ass kicked um
yeah so it was it's like the whiskey was
real cheap i i got that i got a i got a
scholarship there
for theater so that's i guess that's
definitely not i guess it can be tray it
really depends no that's pretty cold i
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah um but you know
like i was
you know and then i just kind of got too
drunk to transfer you know because i i
should have gone to like another school
were you partying a lot in high school
too yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty much do
you still booze no not anymore you're
off unfortunately how long
uh well
a little time this time around
i'm back again like six months back but
that was a slip up and like i've only in
the past like
i don't know like seven years i've maybe
drank
six days okay that's great if that makes
sense
you know that's that's a guy who's been
to the been at the bottom of a bottle
when he
i've drank six dates
five times not nice why i was doing this
the other day
i was like trying to win an argument
with my wife
and i was like i've only drank six days
of these seven years that's great
but when you break it down how many
what's that now i'm pretty sweating by
the way
um
how was how were you in school high
school students fine i mean seem like a
smart girl
we all know you're you're a very smart
guy no i'm not that smart i'm i'm
literally a b-plus like i was like i
wasn't the katy episode i was like like
12 40 or something on sats you know like
not like that's smart but it's awesome
it's not like uh
but it's not like [ __ ] will hunting
like i'm doing like nah sure formulas or
something you know but 12 40 is
fantastic yeah so but i mean it was get
you into evansville i mean evansville
but yeah i should have gone to one of
the other schools but i was just you
know i got too drunk there's a good
question where else did you get accepted
to oh like emerson and syracuse those
are the two emersons syracuse emerson's
a great school yeah i should have done
that what'd you go to but i think i
would be dead like i really do think i
couldn't have a big city yeah yeah yeah
like like 18 they didn't give me any
money and my dad was kind of like a big
deal with the college i went and i think
i was just like too nervous because he
wanted me to go there and i just didn't
have like an identity thing and then i
got that identity in comedy
uh you know like george 23.
turning into what the [ __ ] saw get away
from it why did he want you to go to to
go to that school i mean they had a good
theater program and i have met some like
lifelong friends there there's a lot of
really good actors that came from there
like romney malek came from there oh no
[ __ ] um yeah kelly get us she's on all
the lawn otters and [ __ ] like so there's
a lot of really good really great really
good actors who came from there and i
thought that's kind of what i wanted to
do and
i don't really want to do that now i
mean i'll do it you know if i get it but
i can't i have a hard time memorizing
wines and it's really like you got to
really love
oh yeah it's so not a thing for me
he's a great actor yeah you're very good
he's passionate about i have like no
desire to do it it's like you know the
trick is you have to be like
compelling while relaxed which you have
you know like but every time like i did
it was like i was trying like guilt from
the simpsons trying to like sell a
[ __ ] mercury to somebody
like
get out of my house you know like that
kind of how are you doing today yeah so
pull it back a little bit after a while
i i enjoyed writing more you know more
than stand up or or acting so i gotta
say we've worked together a couple of
times i i have no idea how unraveled you
were and i [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude i love you
this is fantastic um
i want to ask you a little bit a little
more about your childhood we'll get into
a couple we'll pepper in a couple of
questions here
um
what was the name of the street that you
grew up on in rutherford home avenue
this is not bad
i don't know that sounds like a north
korean town
that sounds like an alien made up of
town uh this is where the home is it's
home avenue
it's on house lane that's tough home
everyone that's like a 15 year old lion
to the cops
i'm on 123 main street any town usa
officer i live on road road
what's what was the name of the street
that you lived in on uh up in
westchester
lower trinity pass so that's
so it really goes from home avenue to
archery back we've never had a pass
beans don't burn on the griddle yeah
was called pound ridge is the name of
the town and then upper shad road was
the other one so very like you know like
you know who my father is
who's coming to her
princess diana boulevard yeah
that's pretty classy uh what was the
high school mascot in westchester in
westchester was a fox it's not bad it's
pretty good it was the name of the high
school fox lane
it was called fox lane high school yeah
a little on the nose
hey we're the foxes from fox lane high
school fox lane i don't know if i
answered this what did your mom do my
mom was a teacher and then she like oh
yeah how how what about the the the
parent-teacher scandal what's going on
there what what when she missed she just
lost the election right
oh yeah no yeah she just lost the
election there that wasn't really why
you guys were moving to westchester
right now maybe it was it could have
been okay
honestly it could have been i don't
think it helped our case for staying
there which is fine i got made fun of a
lot so i was all right leaving but like
uh
she was a teacher when you got to
westchester she was a teacher and you're
well no she wasn't she she had taken off
then she started again in westchester
she was volunteering at a prison and
then she was she's good with like
emotionally she was good with
emotionally disturbed kids nice so like
that's kind of what she not not as good
with like normal children but like not
that i'm normal but like like the kids
are like you know i was going to say
who are you talking about
like you know the dangerous minds type
kid
and did she so she didn't work in your
school though right okay
all right that's pretty good what was
the name of the grocery store that you
went to in westchester
that your mom was
i remember the one when i was iga was in
jersey
and then in westchester it was food
emporium so that was a little bit
hoity-toity oh and scott's corners that
was also kind of that sounds classy
that's anything with a first name or a
last name is typically top notch ig
whatever the [ __ ] you say
it's like international grocer's
association
that was the jersey one shop right iga
and shopping nothing wrong with the shop
[ __ ] gentlemen yeah i don't want to
hear anybody slandering the great
institution that is
ig shoprite tell you that right now
have milk with dinner growing up what
did you drink milk with dinner growing
up yeah i gave you milk you have milk
with dinner now no never do it now i
have i'm starting to get in a cereal
again
me too
i just started i just started i've been
six days i i had cereal like my wife a
month ago i'm getting a sprite again
like uh yeah so i've been eating
cinnamon toast crunch at night when i've
uh wanted a drink i've just been having
bowls
in my in my kitchen yeah when i quit
smoking steaks i got really into candy
bars yeah that's there's something about
an adult like angrily eating a candy it
is
i would walk into the deli and buy it
like i was buying a package
like hoping you're a pedophile for your
sake like i hope you're using these on
kids give me a snickers hard pack let's
go
i'd pop up a twix and [ __ ] rip it
rip it out
that's business today
[Laughter]
kippystamps.comstamps.com i'll say it
one more time so it gets into that big
head of yours
stamps.com i know them i love them folks
you don't want to waste time going to
the post office and you can get
discounted rates with stamps.com ups and
usps that's money that you're saving
yeah what could you do to you go see a
movie the theaters are open back up take
your uh your lady or your husband or
your boyfriend or whatever take them on
a trip you're saving money they save
thousands and thousands of small
businesses tons of money you got to get
on it yeah guys stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups right to your computer but you
already know that they've been with the
show a long time they're a fantastic
service we use them uh whether you're a
small business and not invoices you got
a side hustle thing going on an etsy
shop whatever you're doing
stamp.stamps.com can help you're trying
to move some poorly made koozies
stamps.com is your guy we sent out all
of the uh all of the cards all the
koozies our merch goes out we use
stamps.com it's easy-peasy they sent us
the printer we pop it in i load it up
right on this computer right here bing
bang boom prints it out slap the slap
the label on hit the bricks it's a
no-brainer um you can save up to 40 off
post office rates and 66 percent off ups
shipping rates what what are we doing
here guys stop wasting time by going to
the post office go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
garbage you'll get a special offer
includes a four week trial plus free
postage at a digital scale hey big man
no long-term commitments or contracts
we're getting out of here if you don't
like it you don't have to use it but
it's it's not going to be the case so
just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
home page and type in garbage at
stamps.com promo code garbage one more
time stamps.com never go to the post
office again do it
folks this podcast is brought to you by
our good friends at manscaped kippy i
don't know if you know but the summer of
love is coming to an end here yeah all
right the 70s are over sure all right
pack your stuff up from woodstock and
get home and do yourself a favor because
cuffing season's around the corner falls
around the corner you're going to want
to snuggle in you're going to want to be
tight you're going to be intimate with
your lady you got to get the manscape
4.0 lawn mower and clean yourself up and
you don't want to use something else
because god forbid you cut off your
candy corn
because that doesn't happen with the
manscape 4.0 i'll tell you that they got
the light they got the ceramic blade
they got the powerful motor they got the
quietness you can use it in the shower
it's unbelievable yeah guys as you know
it's top-notch they sent them to us
i mean we each have one t-bone's got one
i use it all over i don't stop at my
balls i go i i used to be an idiot i
used to do traditional blade and cream i
got a dog with it all my old ball sack
and then somebody told my dad never told
me how to shave my pubes and one of my
boys is like woody he came over early i
was sitting there with a blading cream
on my you know my my ball bag and my
johnson and he's like dude what are you
doing i didn't know i should have been
using a lawnmower 4.0 this whole time
she should have um guys
uh seal the deal with manscapes uh they
got the crop preserver for you they got
uh the you know the dual blade system
that's the skin safe technology which
helps prevent knicks snags tugs and
those delicate holes yes
you guys can go around back with it too
don't stop at the front baby
uh you get up to 20 off and free
shipping with promo code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with promo code man i'm sorry
with promo code garbage at manscape.com
make your balls a priority this fall
choose manscape your balls will thank
you yes they will kippy let's talk about
our good friends over there helix
mattress is that helix mattress yes it
is you got one i want one i'm waiting on
one top of the line product right there
and let me tell you why as you know
if you go to a mattress store you walk
around like a bozo
okay you're laying on matches that
people have been laying on you don't
know this you don't know that there's
some uh there's there's some salesman
he's out back smoking a bernie breaking
up with his girlfriend doing god knows
what with god knows who he doesn't care
what mattress she gets he doesn't he
wants to sell you the most expensive one
that's right he's probably high on chiba
but not the good people at helix you
know what they do what do they do they
have you take a quick two minute quiz so
they can match you with the perfect
mattress for you if you sleep hot if you
sleep cold if you're a big guy like me
and you need a little more room even
they got you covered then yeah guys uh
it's fantastic like the big man said
they sent one to me and my wife we
hopped online took the two-minute quiz
we got the twilight model uh it's fanta
it's the best sleep i've ever had in my
life i didn't know
that there was a difference between
a shitty mattress and a good mattress i
just always had shitty mattresses but
not anymore it's a game changer so if
you're in the market for a mattress
check out helix uh it's fantastic don't
take my word for it like i've said many
times before they awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine
that ain't no school newspaper folks no
major publications so just go to
helixsleep.com garbage take the real
quick two-minute sleep quiz they'll
match you to a customized matches so
they'll give you the best sleep of your
life they'll have a 10-year warranty and
you'll get to try it out for hundred
nights risk-free it's crazy they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but i'm telling you you will that's
kooky talk so here we go baby we're down
to the bread and butter helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com garbage that's
helixsleep.com
garbage for up to two
hundred dollars ain't baby two hundred
two two hundred fajours not bad pretty
good and two free pillows there you go
so helix sleep.com garbage now back
that's so funny that you said that you
said that you're getting back in this
here because i i feel that way too
because i had an issue for a little
while i rekindled my love affair with
the onion ring and that wasn't good for
anything oh yeah what do you do you like
it more crispy of course you do like it
crispy and crunchy it's weird if it's
just like a soggy onion yeah when it
like separates too much or like whatever
you know what the onion here i like real
onion rings they have like the burger
king ones are fake there's no actual
onion in it but when you get a good
onion ring but then when the [ __ ]
whole onion comes out and then you just
got the crispy [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about what are you doing back
there i mean you definitely eat it but
yeah
what the [ __ ] this guy's on him
that's your sauce honey mustard barbecue
i'm a big big big big big honey mustard
guy yeah i i have all three i just dunk
them and as of late rainbow as of late
i've really gotten into the garlic aioli
oh it's great this cuban place i've been
ordering extra garlic for like my other
meals
i'm gonna have eggs tomorrow send some
more aioli will ya
baby we're cooking here that's what's
[ __ ] bonkers
besides the sauce for meals in the
future yeah that's crazy yeah yeah
that's something
don't you you don't even don't you feel
like a piece of [ __ ] when you go to a
diner because i i like ranch for my
fries of course and then they
like you just want a little thing and
they bring like they bring them they
bring a saucer yeah you're like and they
have to bring it to like through
everybody everyone's got to see you
bring it out like nine places yeah like
it's an ice sculpture to drugs ours
[ __ ] it's kind of they didn't like
they like i always view that as like a
[ __ ] you to me well you know what i mean
it's like oh can i get a side of oh you
want to sign a ranch like we're going to
make it a [ __ ] spectacle they got the
bucket in front
is that enough you want more table 8
okay
very nice very very i i oh man this is
before i was in the ranch i was trying
to use before i was in the ranch i was a
chinese buffet
i i had the soup and it was like
delicious and um and then i went back
and i got more i was like i've never had
this type of soup and then the waiters
right next to her busboy this is a
chinese buffet said ah man this kid
really loves his ranch i like drank i
had like had two full bowls of ranch
like [ __ ]
clam chowder
it was disgusting
this soup's great what is it barbecue
sauce barbecue
it's a human hand
[Laughter]
sir please stop eating me
did you have a garage in the westchester
house um
no not yet no we didn't no garage no we
had a chicken coop but we didn't have a
garage wait
yeah yeah for eggs or pets
eggs
that seems like a real writer thing you
know yeah i mean he doesn't have to he's
not the nine to five
yeah yeah he just checks the a it was
strictly for the egg so it wasn't it was
i mean everyone's gonna watch it you'd
have to like
put one of the chickens out of their
misery because like a fox would come in
and attack him so you'd have to foxlean
so like my dad didn't want to like he
was too nervous to cut the head off so
he would drown the chickens like [ __ ]
good fellas or something like that in
the back
i don't know if you're white trash or
just uh white darkness
but yeah what would he drive they have a
pool really nice pool it was a really
nice did you drown them in the pool no
no they would we have like a bucket of
water you just drown them in there jesus
i mean i'm talking like the the
the chicken was dying and i like chunks
of it ripped out but why wouldn't you
just kill it quickly
i think drowning is probably true
i guess he thought that was the most
painless way to go
so i set the bird on fire
they don't have essential nervousness
donald rumsfeld so i water for him for
three days [ __ ] didn't talk no i
got done pulling on his fingernails
i did him quick what the [ __ ] jesus
how are the eggs top shelf uh pretty
good yeah i mean sometimes you give like
[ __ ] on them and stuff so you gotta wash
them off but pretty good my dad's [ __ ]
my dad would just know i'm just gonna
show you this came up a couple uh a
couple weeks ago but if you got it if
you cracked open an egg you're at your
house you're making eggs crack open an
egg you got two yolks in there what are
you doing what do you mean did you
separate and put them together are you
eating like are you
throwing it away exactly freak you
that's
wow yeah i don't understand
why would it freak you out i don't know
oh oh it's like one egg with two that's
what happened that's like good luck
what kind of dirtball superstition is
that it's good luck
it's going to be a great day
hey guys it's the year of the yolk i
hear what do you want one olson or you
want two holes come on holy [ __ ] that's
good luck
this guy plays by his own rules
his kid's a loose cannon
diabetic lethal weapon
um
all right jesus uh did you get a high
school class ring when you graduated um
if so did you wear it no no i don't
think so no
it's the right
answer you ever have a photograph taken
in a plastic poncho
plastic poncho
not a plastic poncho but a full a
regular one regular poncho where are you
getting a regular poncho i used to do
like the festival circuit so what are
you i'm sorry fan festivals
yeah um who are you following around
uh
like
uh philaletian friends the uh other ones
um
fish of course deep banana blackout um
lake trout
you can stop there
do you guys get that new lake trout
have you ever complained about this
no we would only do the like the little
ones but my friends would do that my
friend had the tank but we were just in
back of the bus we would just do the
little ones you ever haggle over the
prices of acid
uh no and i did the only time i've ever
done acid i've done mushrooms a lot but
the only time i've ever done acid was i
was so [ __ ] blacked out drunk and
coked out i don't know how much i paid
for it i don't remember tripping at all
so that sounds good
this all sounds healthy
[Laughter]
i mean how [ __ ] up on booze and coat
you have to be to not remember an
eight-hour acid trip
probably my friend think about it dude
i've been [ __ ] up like god is not
happening on it like that was my whole
thing it was all true she woke up
you guys come back you guys read it out
of this you're like this is this is
nothing like what he described you never
read
i was going out with a chicken farm um
that's funny because my next question
was have you ever been to a concert
twice yeah yeah um you weren't banned
twice or something like that yeah like
going to like if if the grateful dead's
in town well they're grateful that's a
different animal
okay yeah that's different it's like the
killers are in town and you go friday
and saturday you're oh i haven't done
like that thing no i have friends that's
their [ __ ] like they'll do a whole
weekend yeah and then like write reviews
on the different shows and stuff
we were talking about this the other
night um not to encourage anything but
when i went to college
um right outside of philadelphia 95 96
and the dead was still like torn torn
yeah and when those bozos would even get
near town that campus was flush with
whatever you want it just oh really oh
man it brought a wave of everything in
yeah that's the thing is you just go
you know like now like if you want yeah
if you want like downers you'd go to a
festival
and if you want uppers you just go to a
gay bar and i said
who the [ __ ] calls them uppers
jordan
saint germain's whacked out on leonard
this guy's [ __ ] popping loose you
know like poppers and you know sex
uppers down or sideways this guy's on
goofball i've got a lot of my wife to do
everything
i remember a kid in high school took 10
uppers and 10 downers thinking to see if
they would cancel each other out 1500 on
the sats
he did not he got his name was will
hunting
he got escorted out in first period on a
stretcher
i passed that once in my high school
before his classes started why too many
youtubers i had a half bottle of captain
morgan in the back oh jesus pirate dude
captain morgan before senior year
almost got kicked whose barrel is this
it's a gun in my mouth
uh your sailboat is parked in the
teacher's parking lot
and it will be removed uh i'll find a
musket in st
locker
[Laughter]
what were the family vacations like in
the st germain household growing up um i
feel like your dad would go to like a
cabin in the woods we did well i do that
now that's more my thing now but like we
did typical stuff we did like disney
world and
um uh which is not you know that was
nice that we go down the shore a lot
what sure long beach island lbi class
that's a very classy establishment this
is too crowded now let me ask you this
when
coming from rutherford to westchester
did you know as a kid in seventh grade
that oh wow we're
we got a lot of money now were you able
to tell that difference or were you kind
of i definitely you know like um
like did the bike start showing up into
this and that well there was just
certain things that you know like i was
privileged enough like i didn't i didn't
have to take our college loans you know
for sure that was like something um
you know that i think that that's the
biggest one because a lot of my friends
would need you know with college some of
them were paid for but there there were
also people in that area with so much
more money mm-hmm sure yeah
i mean
not even that like new new real money
because then you know my dad like we
kind of moved there and then my dad
stopped you know getting as much money
yeah yeah luckily then some plays picked
up after that um he had like a
successful play in new york but like you
know it was uh it's not like um
you know like when you're in
entertainment it's never [ __ ] you money
because it can all go away exactly and
it's like for 10 years you don't make
anything and then for a handful of years
you make a lot of money and then it all
goes away again so it's like forgotten
like you would think you know i've had
years like that where it's like you
think you're i'm in completely different
tax brackets like one year you're like
holy [ __ ] then two years later you're
like am i that guy's pa now
you know believe me we watch the patreon
numbers like to the nuclear clock
checking that thing like a newborn now
every 20 minutes
you know what i mean kid join the
wrestleros patreon
there you go
go join it
anybody in your family ever live in a 55
or older community that wasn't 55
uh wait no no nobody's nobody's done
that there's over 50. nothing trashy
like that no i mean no no
no your parents smoke
my mom used to smoke uh they they don't
my mom may now smoke again i'm not sure
uh that's a whole other story but uh
yeah my mom smoked on and off and i i
smoked my sister smokes
anyone in your family own an old their
own pool cue or bowling ball no but not
athletic for the most part i love how
those are sports
[Laughter]
no tight ends or no bowlers
any dart players no we don't have any
olympians
sorry my last name's not phelps
did your parents leave the butter on the
counter they put it in the fridge uh
there's been different phases what about
you right now it's it's in the fridge
now really yeah okay my wife
what about uh you pee in the shower i
have you you brush your teeth in the
shower
i have before yes but it's not a regular
thing brush your teeth and shower no
only when i'm drinking
why so well i don't know i just because
it's all because you pee and then you
spit the tooth and you have the drink
you know you do all three
oh you're drinking
i'm starting to put together that six
day thing yeah
i think that was six days straight
you know maybe oh and you're drinking of
course what kind of milk is in those
cinnamon toast crunch captain morgan
uh do you currently own a working
printer
uh no but we gotta get one cause i just
got [ __ ] my ass reamed because i i
had to print out a script from kinko's
cost me like forty dollars at the print
show dude it's crazy insane it's like
what am i getting this on like quill
we should we should either
figure something out or stop printing
things i think it's got i think
technology
they used to break and then you run out
of ink and it was so expensive i think
it's back to where it's like easy to own
again yeah i think so i don't think we
really need to put anything on paper
scripts is different that is a pain in
the ass to read something like that on
an ipad you know yeah it was just one of
those things i was like the last i just
wanted to do one last strap like one
last look through on paper and i was
like this is dumb
who yelled at you out of curiosity
yelled at me you said you got reamed for
oh
oh financially yeah i felt like someone
was mad at you for spending 40 on the
scripture my wife beat me
no no no
okay my wife and i are both bad with
money you know that's what helps
i'm a little better i guess what does
she do my wife is in uh casting oh cool
nice okay so you probably maybe you've
got it for i don't know
yeah we'll talk off here
set up
maybe it's sardis we'll talk this over
here she'll show all those glasses
give me a towel
hello dan and mrs dan
it's been a long time oh man um ever
have the dish known as beer can chicken
no once again i don't think so no i
don't think i've ever had because that
is the
captain crunch chicken but not beer
canned chicken oh no that's perfect what
the [ __ ]
captain crunch chicken yeah yeah yeah
captain crunch
i mean you got to be like it you got to
be ready for it you got to be drinking
well let me ask you this just you know
in case the listeners want to know where
would somebody pick up i don't see
something like that i don't think you
buy it you make it you [ __ ] take a
captain crunch and chicken they don't
have it someone buy that there's this
french chef
next time you're in paris ask around
i thought you might have had it like one
of those cookie joints in astoria like
no no this is a queen that's a
comfortable kid yeah you could do with
any cereal
like corn flake chicken you know
cornflake chicken i've had yes
[Laughter]
alfredo
that's too much
count chocula scampi
that's it that's the winner
we got there that's a writer's name
it's going to be whoever the third one
is
that was great though whoever the third
one is
you just can't use your scampi is a
funny word
even the fourth one could be great and
it's over yeah uh rule of threes um do
you fold or hang your t-shirts
um which ones the t-shirts i fold you
fold your t-shirts like you get folded
and get put in a dress you said which
ones well it depends on the type of
shirt you know like because i got
you know i got living in shirts
that are like more like capes you know
with like different stains on them
uh like more like capes
you know
like that where's my cape at it's so you
know how like your your you know like
girlfriend
wear like boyfriend shirts like it's
like i'm wearing like bigfoots like you
have like my boyfriend yeah yeah yeah
yeah nice i love those
you got a suit in the house right now
i have parts of a suit like i have a
coat they don't all go together but i
have a calvin klein coat and then i have
a black pants
uh all black pants
i got a button down you look like you
would have a suit of armor
we did have one growing up he shows up
to the emmys in a full night outfit
dan who are you wearing well i'd be i'd
[ __ ] be happy for cable ace awards at
this point wait you actually had a suit
of armor in your house
yeah but it was like artistic armor it
wasn't like real dad that's probably the
dad yeah yeah yeah he would have it in
his my dad had armor in his writing room
right now oh get away with [ __ ] wow
that's [ __ ] hold on a second that
might wash away everything you've said
really yeah
yeah what's everywhere and all that kind
of stuff oh yeah books are everywhere
did you write it in a typewriter
originally type writer than a computer
i don't know man he might have just
turned me around one of those night
suits that's cool it's very my life is
very contradictory it's very
contradictory
it's very tough it's like
it's like fine trash
those things always came to life in
scooby-doo though i never trusted them
that's pretty classy though but it
wasn't like real how come you don't got
no night suit at your place i'm not
trash what do you thought i'm letting
you go thinking that's cla it's not like
he lives in it it's not like he lives in
a castle or something he lives in west
chester with chickens that's pretty
sweet though
oh man
do your parents or you ever leave the tv
on when you're not home to make people
think that you are home yeah i did that
yeah you did well i do it for my dogs
now sure of course talking to you
what's it like to watch what what do you
put on for him i try to put on cartoons
i don't think they give a [ __ ]
i know he's never asked for anything
specific put the news on
china i told you chinatown for the last
time
um you travel a lot back and forth kind
of by coastal do you have name brand
luggage
no no no
one of our one of our suitcases is
samsonite but just because it was at
marshalls yeah it was like the sturdiest
one
i don't think that's the name brand we
were looking for but
my wife got me a nice cole haan bag
roller or dust no duff yeah now if
you're waiting in line at the airport
and you have the duffel
and like the the line's incrementally
moving up do you pick up the duffel or
do you kick it to the next spot in line
i pick up the cole haan but my duff my
other duffel you'll kick yeah yeah
that's a that is a that is a mark of
trash i do it too just sliding your
[ __ ] luggage i'll do the kick for the
if it's like a shitty like jan sport or
whatever are you tsa pre-screened
pre-checked no pre-check no i need to do
that but now i actually don't because i
don't really travel to do stand up do
you always do you ever fly first class
i i have a couple times but i haven't
but usually i usually splurge myself
usually i'm college i i sports for the
extra room
which i think is like that's if you do
enough on the road you end up like
that's sure yeah you just want to
[ __ ] spread out a little bit what's
uh what's the credit situation credit
good credit bad credit's good great it's
good we we we were bad for a little bit
and then we fixed it uh credit cards
what do you roll with you have an amex
uh we've just two visa two visas
roundabout what's the credit limit
combined i can't tell i couldn't tell
you i really couldn't that's enough
that's enough yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
cash right there that in a night suit
come on
[Laughter]
have you ever worn a basketball jersey
with no t-shirt on yes i did that
recently i wear my lebron uh lakers
jersey
you know it's nowhere anywhere
comfortable well i'm [ __ ] now because
i bought this charles barkley one and
then there's allen iverson when he was
in georgetown one but like
it's too tight so i gotta lose the
weight and they're my gold jerseys
they're hanging he's got him framed
but we were just talking about that have
you ever bought clothes
i have gold the thing that fat guys wear
yeah
it's a good move on the beach i got a
goal
have a gold burlap sack
i'm trying to wear a hillbilly wedding
uh have you ever been in a bouncy castle
as an adult yes oh also there's well
there's also one like if you're in the
museum of sex in new york they have like
a bad thing yeah
so it's like does that count i don't
know because it's like that's like kind
of chic you know like i don't know i'm
gonna check it out
my two favorite things titties and
bouncy
what a horrifying thing to walk into
something on a huge boob just [ __ ]
just torturing himself
um
do you eat thai food yes
love it
what was that where were you going with
that that's classy okay just yeah i just
wow that's yeah thai food's classy sure
i completely agree so so i think it says
more about you that you think it's
classy it's true
we have a low bar around here like
that's a whole country you can't just
say toby cut that
i don't know thai food the night thing
this kid's looking pretty good he's got
one he's got thai food okay and then the
night thing come on
we're stretching here captain crunch
chicken
captain morgan's before school a real
debate guys have you ever had a birthday
cake that was a cheesecake
no i don't think so ice cream a lot of
ice cream cakes yeah gentlemen that's a
gentleman's kid yeah that's a gentleman
leave it out for five ten minutes
[ __ ] perfect
god i love a good ice cream cake yeah i
love ice cream cake have you ever
watched the tv show pit bulls and
parolees no okay wait
wait i've watched i've been on hippos
i've done the one where they do the dogs
in prison but that's like more of a
documentary okay thing you know
and the one where the guy murdered a
bunch of women and he had cats
oh yeah i know exactly
i don't think i know that one and that
sounds right up my canadian guy yeah i
think so yeah yeah yeah you know what
i'm talking about the white mom and the
daughter or whatever yeah he was a real
psycho yeah uh ever been shouted out on
a game show
ever been shouted out shouted out not on
a game show have you ever heard somebody
say i want to say hi to dan no no no
any family members ever on the local
news um
it depends on oh yeah maybe
mom probably my dad yeah for good
reasons most likely but i've had ants
who probably have been honest out front
of like yeah
do you uncles currently wear pajamas
no what's the sleep situation
[ __ ] man way i've just been all i'm
buying is athletic shorts that's it like
i just basketball shorts uh yeah just
basketball shorts because i don't have
to go anywhere i'm not doing stand-up
right now dude i'm [ __ ] with him it's
unbelievable it's great i'm get i'm not
losing any of this weight but like oh i
go i basically live in a three i hang
out my wife i have a couple friends i
see and then we got the dog park across
the street and that's basically my life
you know
and that's in l.a that's here that's
here yeah nice
we're gonna move soon but yeah it's uh
it's it is here's the thing about these
villages great it's like venice in la
where it's like
yes there's people with a lot of money
there but it's also like there are
people shooting up like sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's got some grit to it
still yeah it's very it's got the best
of both worlds yeah
is there a painting
of your family in your in in your dad's
home or your mom's home was there ever a
painting
i've had
paintings of our dogs commissioned
[Laughter]
my wife and our dog mushu we have a toy
maltipoo i did it like clarice and
sounds the lambs the lamb i had it done
well that's fun for that
that's just funny yeah
have you ever ridden a mechanical bull
yes
how many times are we talking here a
couple they're like the drinking days i
presume you're at the bar yeah yeah you
ride roller coasters yes you ever pass
out on a roller coaster never passed out
you ever get a picture taken when you
were going over the top of a roller
coaster yes
wow and you buy the picture when you get
down to that splash mountain we would
all the time but like uh i don't think
of the roller coaster now what about the
slingshot you ever been in that nope
never done this is there any video of
you or any family member in the
slingshot anywhere no sir hmm have you
ever bought a pair of sketchers
no sir like it was a deposition yeah
yeah
i have not bought a pair of sketchers
maybe when i was no i didn't just vance
you own a pair of crocs no uggs
nope
ever use zack's body spray yes
recently not recently it would irritate
my testicles so i stopped wait you put
it on your balls i thought that's what
you did
that's not what you do
he answered that so earnestly i thought
that's what you did it was a bad time in
my life
dude i'm laughing at the phrase
irritated my testosterone
who the [ __ ] says that i used to burn my
nuts and irritated my testicles
oh that's beautiful
that is beautiful um
since we were in the in the shower a
little bit what are we using a loofah
we're using a bar we're using body wash
i've used a bar and bought now i always
body wash i use bar in college and my
early 20s mid-20s like when i when i
when i had like a steady girlfriend or
my wife it changed a body wash my wife
won't let me use the loofah because of
like uh
a thing that happened uh yeah yeah just
i don't know man we had to throw the
loofah out you know uh so please
elaborate yeah i just got i got [ __ ] on
the luffy you know
we had to get a new loofah so uh
you know that wasn't great i both we
both knew what it was we were like
elaborate i got [ __ ] on the
loofah that's why you got to get two of
the again his and hers yeah my
girlfriend would never touch anything
that's touched my body would never touch
her body in the shower yeah or the
bedroom huh what nothing on that
um well it's like when you with somebody
like you know in the beginning you do
all this like kinky sexual stuff and
then they then she sees you eat yeah you
know let's stick with the basics
let's stick with you guys in your
mustache yeah yeah yeah i'm thinking
about getting i don't want you to think
my pussy's a gyro
depending on depending on what part of
the town part of town
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's good
uh when was the last time you made fish
sticks
a very long time i'm not really a
fixture guys i like fish and chips but
okay do you guys cook at home are you
ordering in uh mostly order and
sometimes cook okay but basic stuff like
like what a frozen stuff and like turkey
and [ __ ] like that you know turkey
sandwiches electric toothbrush no
a water pick i have two no i have two
regular toothbrushes dude what are they
for why
i got a whole package and i used them
both so so but they're both out well
one's in one area of the bathroom and
the other one's in the other area of the
bathroom so whatever i remember
how big is the bathroom it's really
small yeah it's in each village
this guy's got two toothbrushes i don't
trust it i'll tell you that right now
i've never been so off put by an
enhancer in my life
how about a water pick
no
you floss every little bit for one time
i did but no really no
uh mouthwash yes scope or listerine um
right now with serene
regular or blue
whatever the stuff that that doesn't
have the alcohol in it okay yeah good
very good yeah softer stuff good stuff
uh purple [ __ ] the purple stuff gotcha
yeah that's good stuff to like the light
purple stuff um do you currently have on
matching socks
yep okay
checks out
are you currently wearing underwear yep
this kid's pretty good have you ever had
to have a beehive removed from your
house
yes well no hornet's nest not a beehive
that you had to get it like
professionally removed yeah they had to
take it out wow
so that was that was like westchester so
that was a nice
yeah it makes sense yeah yeah there's a
lot of trees and [ __ ] there it'd be
tough it was in the if it was in the
east village apartment
mr saint germain i ain't never seen this
before
uh when was the last time you were in a
wave pool
um probably on like a
like a big oh years like probably like
years and years ago okay
like i think it was like an awareness
that resort gotcha yeah that's pretty
classy i think that i think in j i don't
i've never been but i've had a lot of my
family members go which makes me think
it's trashy i think it's what trashy
people think is classy
so yeah that's what that's the thing
it's like hot tubs like if you depending
on how your opinion about because like
when i was a standalone hot tub is we've
gone on record is like what this show is
based around is the trashiest thing you
can own yeah yeah
we had that
like growing up and then i thought that
that was like
like the classiest thing and then you
would get in like with all your family
members and see like you know they're
you know you're like this is not and
charles
i'm living in a [ __ ] petri dish right
now everybody's got boogers hanging out
yeah it's just losing my heart on over
here
have you ever hunted for bigfoot
no i've never hunted for bigfoot but
i've been to a lot of different bigfoot
memorabilia shops in the northwest
because uh it it goes all the way up and
uh
you know i enjoy it i enjoy the i've
bought some bigfoot stuff would you or
is that something that's on the list
like you want to go hunting maybe one
day for bigfoot yeah no because i don't
think that bigfoot's real okay oh so
it's just more like the i think some of
that stuff real i don't like bigfoot's
real have you ever been ghost hunting
no no
no ever stayed at a haunted house not
yet we go to a lot of haunted houses
like hay rides and stuff like that yeah
probably a good time we'll probably go
to haunted house this this fall of
course yeah that kind of stuff i meant
like an actual haunted house there's
like apparently some tim burton bar near
us but that seems like it's the reviews
are really bad on yelp so i don't know
if we're gonna go tim burton in the east
village yeah like a block away from us
so it's called the beetle bar
i don't know i don't think i've ever let
him make my mozzarella sticks like
sweetie todd beef like yeah
you know
yeah werewolf potato tots like that kind
of place all of the edward scissorhands
nachos yeah yeah yeah do you work alone
failed actor spitting in your [ __ ]
your mummy pasta
do you wear cologne uh i did i don't
anymore i used to wear um michael quartz
blue
pretty good do you like quail eggs
uh i've never had coil i think maybe
i've had it once maybe
but not enough that i i remember it
being fine it was you know it was like
kind of like cornish gay man right
mm-hmm it's all right they rated a
quiznos oh yeah hmm
interesting
but they were hot for a minute they were
good there was one right near my head i
enjoyed it for a while because they had
the special also the salad dressing
you'd think the this nice little i
forget what it was but the horseradish
sandwich you just in the dressing was
good horseradish cream yeah but it was
something else yeah um if i called your
cell phone right now would and i got the
voicemail would it be hey this is dan
i'm not here whatever or would it be the
number or the worst name it's not set up
or full no it would be the name but
nothing like um are you speaking it yeah
okay i believe it's i would i believe
it's me yeah but it's nothing it's not
fun either it's not like a fun no no
that's good if you have if you're an
adult and you have one of the hey how
you doing what's that can't hear you
that i got you i'm not here that is a
tough look let me ask you this that's
rough man your standup comedian in new
york city you start you start getting
some writing i've never done stand-up
since may no but i mean you you have
done it yeah you're like you're a
comedian yeah yeah i did i mean i did it
yeah you make it sound like you did it
one time man you're very accomplished no
i did it for a while but i just i
haven't done it in like four i mean the
last gig i did was like end of may i
have like three months you're out when's
the how many long before you're out no
not at all i'm painting a picture i was
okay all right all right what i was
gonna say is you're you're you're
although he's dying
the guy who wrote uh 12 years a slave i
guess was on he was on marin and then
like marion well let's talk about the
time he used to host a comic strip
because that's what he he started out he
goes yeah that's a part of my life i
don't talk about it anymore like he does
not talk about his time as a stand-up i
got it well what i was getting at is
you're new you're a comedian you start
getting some writing jobs my question is
when you got your first big paycheck
yeah did you go out and buy anything
stupid with it not was there ever
depends on
i mean do relapses count because that's
a whole different i mean that's a whole
different thing sure no no for me as far
as like you spend like two grand on a
wwf jacket or something no i never spent
that i spent the most i spent was like
four hundred dollars on wwe belt because
i like to get them signed to conventions
and [ __ ] let's see uh but i would i
would buy like uh nice new balances
and um i i do like to go to the spa i
did like to go to the spa and then you
know like
you know like when you're you know if
you're blacked out you know then there's
other purchases that are sure dumb um
yeah but that's that's like a different
uh yeah yeah yeah of course that's not
that's a that's a different thing yeah
as far as you know um so yeah what not
to not that's good that all sounds very
responsible
yeah we moved a few trips but nothing
too crazy
how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken love it
how about the hawaiian
i don't know i don't i like pineapple i
don't know if i like it on my pizza
every once in a while i've had it and
it's been fine but i just i don't you
know i don't know
i don't know i can't trust it
not bad not bad you ever owned any num
chuck swards or chinese stars
uh i think i had nunchucks when i was a
kid like but i might be like like toy
nunchucks yeah yeah yeah yeah not like
real um as far as a sword no i think i
had like a hunting knife or something
okay i forgot what injuries did you
sustain as a child
broken arms pretty good i mean the worst
thing that happened is i fell off my
bunk bed and like
onto my penis and then i had to like uh
i was like the weirdest one for a
he made it sound like his penis was
already on the ground when he fell wait
did you have an erection yeah ah
why did you wait you went off the top
ropes onto your [ __ ] hard-on
anyway i don't want to talk about it
yeah yeah yeah but it was that was that
was rough uh but yeah i mean you know i
got i threw out my back out on bunny
hill and [ __ ] like i have back problems
now but i never broke anything that's
good yeah
all right i got one we used to do we
used to do a decent event cold stuff
like a wrestling pull stuff sure yeah
ever have impentago or ring worm
no
no it's not an animal
um you're your local mall right
westchester wherever it's uh dinner time
you're at the food court right you got
one place to go to get a meal where are
you going
it depends on is this like a sacrifice
meal full meal it's dinner time you're
not gonna eat until the next day the
fact that you said it depends already
made you garbage
so i want you're playing with house
money right now
i mean like every once in a while i
would do like the philly cheesesteak and
then as a side get the aunt annie's
pretzels and then like an orange julius
so you got like three
why not if you're at a food court you
gotta [ __ ] i respect that you gotta
you gotta like set you gotta like uh you
know i mean you guys get it
come heavier don't come you're the only
person that in
other than my family that i've ever
connected with on the orange julius oh
it's real good i feel like it wasn't in
all places though
comedians like percentage of wise how
many people were garbage that come on
the show 97 yeah everybody yeah yeah
everybody except like has there ever
been not garbage a comedian that wasn't
yeah uh jared freed
uh chris allen who chris allen chris
allen karen feehan karen feehan was
classy uh chas palmitari
but i mean that's given yeah um i think
that's it right i mean i mean i mean
there's definitely been some but
mostly shane torres you guys said it was
classic i think shane torres was pretty
classy
yeah yeah yeah but you're in good
company
yeah you're trash for sure i mean you
would need i mean i thought there was a
good in the third i think it was a
debatable the first third right
it was the dad really pulled you out
of the culture and he's got you know you
got your own chickens for the just for
the eggs to me the chickens took you
down
when i went to nicaragua like for my
church we bought i bought a stuffed
chicken that was on my dad's land i
brought that home like a stuffed rooster
okay let's take a minute and touch on
this
what's the church
it was a presbyterian church there's
nothing there what'd you guys go down
there for building houses in los pilas
orientalists it was we should have just
given money like that they how long were
you down there for it's a week you know
how many houses did you get up in that
week like one two one or two
you know and it was like you know
obviously the [ __ ] nicaraguans were
like way harder workers than us you know
it's a weird thing to like go down there
and you're like ooh third world but it's
like they have a higher literacy rate
than us yeah you know like it it's you
have no construction background yeah for
the most part there there's no
construction background yeah for the
most part they've been [ __ ] over by
you know american money in the cia going
again sure you know the same nieces and
[ __ ]
man well that's pretty classy to do that
i think sure yeah i guess
i mean
i don't think it's pulling them out no
no
i mean i told him he can choose one
thing at the food court and he named
three places yeah yeah
he got an appetizer one place to drink
at another and
an entree at the cheesesteak place
i'm pretty s i'm pretty [ __ ] secure
here i mean i know i know a way i'm
ruling i don't need any more
cross-examination i don't think no
he's trash yeah yeah
just checking i'm just checking we're
all in the same way he thought i had a
shot there on the first third i was like
oh it looks like it i could really pull
this off no
that's the thing uh oh sam roberts two
was classy but then we just didn't get
to hit a lot of people
through the lineup as it gets further on
in the show we tighten the [ __ ] screw
once we realize your background and
stuff like that yeah so we'll get it if
it's there we'll get it 99 you wrote for
the correspondence center were you
actually there for that i was there for
that with the tux and everything yes he
had the jacket how was the food
terrible really awful you were at one of
like the tables tables
you got the rest of the food that the
president was eating awful
the president wasn't there it was just
sarah huckabee sanders oh yeah oh so it
was for the michelle wolfe one right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah gotcha
it was like a little steak medallion it
was really bad it was like really bad
like shockingly bad damn
um what hotel was that at it's a nice
hotel he hasn't only got a famous hotel
every year down there the car liar or
whatever i think it was the car i forget
what the hotel was damn i want i wasn't
the watergate i don't know that's
getting a nice cheese taken apart
i love dc so
i love it yeah i like it yeah mr saint
germain i believe this was a [ __ ]
whirlwind you are
garbage yeah
thanks for having
me man thanks for coming in
i haven't like acid you know this is a
great podcast so i appreciate you guys
oh we love it man we wanted to have you
on this is absolutely fine no it's a
sincere comment because i couldn't make
eye contact
any vulnerability that two men can have
with one another thank you i will get
the boba fett in the background you see
a tear go down my cheek
i love you too buddy
[Laughter]
staring at the solo cups
that's your time i wasn't trying to be
dead i was trying to be you
oh [ __ ] what's that from it's from uh
star wars born yes yes
damn that was good that's the most manly
sam elliott cry in there but he knows
like he like does the cry in reverse he
reverses the car and you see it yeah
he's really good man he gets he gets me
choked up all the time yeah um that's
your camera right there you got anything
coming up you want them to oh
anybody who's a wrestling fan that
listens to this show uh you should
listen to wrestler rose it's a really
fun show it's me mike lawrence robert
carpolis does the w creativist feel
scott chaplin i think he's done 100
percent
chaplain great he's the mvp of the show
uh so yeah check it out man i mean it's
we had a fun patreon and it's and if you
don't like wrestling
you know
you may not like it but if you if you
like it if you like it please check it
out i think it would be your favorite
wrestling podcast if you like wrestling
awesome dude this is kids goes yeah
kippy what do you got for uh as guys
thanks for tuning in at cameron comedy
on all social media make sure you rate
view subscribe youtube patreon the whole
nine yards uh tejas we're gonna be in
texas come out tonight let's [ __ ] go
get some ticks the september 21st
through the 26th we'll be in texas
we're gonna be in moon tower we're going
to san antonio houston and fort worth as
well get some [ __ ] merch we're
sitting on about ten thousand koozies
that we haven't sold [ __ ] get them
gang we love you st germain we love you
buddy thank you so much
thanks thank you for having me guys of
course anytime we'll see you guys next
week
peace peace appreciate it what an hour
buddy thanks guys
thank you thank you for having me